foot pads socks and shoes we are not
talking about your typical day at the
spa but for those in need many say kind
of felt like a spa day it's a local
non-profit and the courtyard homeless
Resource Center coming together to
provide care for the homeless a news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough giving us a
look
get some shoes get your feet washed and
clean there's a lot of people here that
need that service what seems so simple
to most can be one of the hardest things
for someone experiencing homelessness
self-care and proper Footwear Friday
over at the courtyard homeless Resource
Center those with Hope Christian Health
Center took time to help people like
Raphael and others through their hands
of Hope Day event providing foot baths
toiletries socks and shoes to those in
need the fact that it's being done with
with the goodness and the kindness of
people that they're not being looked
down upon are like they're you know
scaven Society CEO of Hope Christian
Health Center Stephen Flores says that
Friday's turnout was even bigger than
before when they had their first event
last November first time we predicted 75
we saw 148
so far today we're already near 160. and
shares with eight news now just how
amazing it is the information you can
gain about a person's health just by
looking at their feet while we wash the
feet we can inspect defeat there's
there's many health indicators that we
identify in the feet and it could be old
sores it could be issues attributed to
diabetes other infections I'm a type 2
diabetic so as a good service provider
especially if you're on your feed and
you're walking around all day
so yeah it was pretty nice those
benefiting from these Services thankful
that something like this is provided
especially with the hotter weather
conditions upon us it's nice to be able
to have a place safer
than just being out there without any
protection